these action stars had major roles in
really big pictures during the genres
heyday in the 80s and 90s but they all
ended their career with a big question
mark wondering whatever happened to
these well muscled men and women we've
got the answers you've been looking for
Vernon Wells personified a very specific
type of 1980s villain the guy who always
seemed to have his wardrobe on loan from
an adult club it started with his role
in Mad Max road warrior in which he
played shoulder-padded Mohawk madman
Weds wells also appeared as rancic a
recurring villain in Power Rangers time
force in a role that seemed cut from the
same cloth as Wes if I can't rule the
present then I'll just ruled his other
prominent role was as the over-the-top
villian Bennett in commando these days
wells looks more like a dad than a
leather daddy and he has a sense of
humor about his characters becoming gay
icons but to this day still swears there
was no sexual subtext intended these
days Welles has been keeping himself
busy with bit parts and voice acting but
mostly can be found focusing his career
behind the camera directing and
producing he also works with Wolf
Connection a nature preserved to
domesticate wolves and allow bonding
with visitors and campers in aliens
Jeanette Goldstein made a name for
herself by playing the tough no-nonsense
Vasquez hey Vasquez have you ever been
mistaken for a man no have you she also
had roles as Megan Shapiro in lethal
weapon 2 and the foster mother of John
Connor in Terminator 2 Judgment Day
Goldstein remains extremely proud of her
shanwa and gender defying role for good
reason now she owns a company Janette
bras named after herself naturally she
founded the company when she realized
department store lingerie departments
were rarely accommodating for women with
smaller band sizes combined with larger
cup sizes probably best known for
playing the immortal swordsman Connor
MacLeod in cult 1986 hit Highlander
Christopher Lambert seemed destined for
action movie stardom there
the only one
but while he popped up in a handful of
other action properties in the 90s he
couldn't escape the shadow of the
Highlander when the big offers stopped
coming and b-movies loomed he decided to
branch out with some new business
ventures including a winery in Provence
apparently they all took off still he
occasionally appears in modern action
movies like when he appeared as the
villain in kickboxer retaliation sunny
lambda made the big time as billy salt a
tracker from the mercenary team
slaughtered in predator
he also made appearances in the Warriors
48 hours and many more 80s action flicks
his acting career dwindled in the mid
90s as he devoted more time to his
political career but it came to a
screeching halt in 2008 after a radio
show gone wrong while he was campaigning
for a Kentucky Senate position on the
libertarian ticket after an increasingly
unhinged rant the Libertarian Party
withdrew their support for Landon's
candidacy after that he appeared in a
couple rolls for low-budget horror films
like disintegration and mental scars
Lanham passed away in August 2017 of
congestive heart failure
naima high-stakes profession and the
chances are Jesse Ventura has dabbled in
it at some point a Vietnam War vet this
former Navy SEAL and Rolling Stones
bodyguard made a name for himself as a
professional wrestler in the early 80s
before making the move to the big screen
he got to rub shoulders with genre
kingpin Arnold Schwarzenegger on
multiple occasions perhaps most notably
in 1987's predator Ventura played the
bullish tobacco-chewing gunner Blaine
Cooper in the classic film and he almost
upstaged the leading man despite a
limited amount of screen time you're hit
you're bleeding man I ain't got time to
be
okay Ventura made another notable
appearance in 1993's demolition man but
by the end of that decade he had
switched his focus to politics becoming
the governor of Minnesota from 1999 to
2003 although he started on the New York
theater circuit Peter Weller eventually
headed out west in search of movie work
arriving in Hollywood during the action
movie boom
Weller gave viewers a glimpse of what he
was capable of in campy 1984 action
satire The Adventures of Buckaroo Banzai
and Paul Verhoeven apparently liked what
he saw enough to cast Weller and what
would become a career-defining role
officer Alex Murphy aka Robocop what are
your prime directors serve the public
trust protect the innocent uphold the
law the film was a success critically
and financially and would eventually be
regarded as a sci-fi movie classic
unfortunately for Weller 1990s Robocop 2
was a bog-standard action movie with all
the gore but none of the heart that made
the 1987 original a success he
eventually moved behind the camera for
work directing several episodes of sons
of anarchy and even appearing in front
of the camera for the sixth and seventh
seasons Weller became a literature and
Fine Arts teacher at New York Syracuse
University for a time putting his
master's degree in Renaissance art
history to good use
he continues to act though making
appearances in television shows like the
last ship and forever Charles Bronson
was a no-nonsense tough-guy even before
he started his acting career way back in
the 1950s born to Lithuanian immigrants
he fought in World War two in order to
escape the grueling conditions at the
mine his family worked for during which
he received a Purple Heart after taking
theater classes while supporting himself
with odd jobs
Bronson eventually moved to Hollywood
where he took on television roles in the
70s Bronson starred in his most famous
role vigilante Paul Kersey in the death
wish films.the drawl served him well
through three sequels in the 80s earning
him a rough-and-tumble reputation he
embellished with tales of his arrests
and violent hobbies all of which he
completely made-up Bronson's gritty
archetype through archaic in the 90s but
what ultimately ended his career was hip
surgery in 1998 he struggled with health
problems afterwards
eventually passing away in 2003 at the
age of 81 taking over from Roger Moore
as James Bond was never going to be easy
but it was a chance that Timothy Dalton
grabbed with both hands the classically
trained actor made his debut in 1968 the
lion in winter but had failed to climb
the ladder from character actor to star
bond was his chance to do just that even
though he only played double-oh-seven
twice in 1987's The Living Daylights and
then again in 1989 'the license to kill
both of his appearances were ultimately
well received by the critics would you
get me a medium trifle komotini
why she stood a contract dispute between
Eon Productions and MGM to lay Dalton's
propose third outing as bond and gave
the actor a legal way out he decided to
call it quits so he wouldn't be forever
remembered as bond but that's what
happened anyway still he didn't stop
acting he's appeared in Edgar Wright's
Hot Fuzz had a recurring guest role in
the TV series Chuck and starred as Sir
Malcolm Murray in Penny dreadful Michael
B knows his stint as an 80s action
started James Cameron who cast him in
three of his earliest films being played
Kyle Reese in 1984 s The Terminator
Hicks in 1986 as aliens and coffee in
1989 s the abyss giving him plenty of
fans and sci-fi and horror circles the
most iconic of those characters wound up
being Kyle Reese though at the time Bean
had no idea just how big the Terminator
would become
come with me if you want to live being
told din of geek that people talk about
it being an iconic movie with iconic
characters and so on but it was never
that back then and you have to remember
too that Arnold was not a superstar he
was basically a bodybuilder in mr.
universe
Schwarzenegger went on to cement his
action hero status with 1987's predator
but for being that star-making role
never came his most noteworthy
appearances since have been in 1996 as
the rock and 2007's planet terror taking
part in Planet Terror rekindled a love
for B movies that Beene forgot he had
and inspired him to start his own
production company specializing in
grindhouse style features
[Music]